what are things you see most beginning
writers sort of get wrong with writing
an outline plot it's so many writers
think that writing an outline is
figuring out their plot okay and and and
and it's there's something very
satisfying about coming up with a plot
there's something that way oh oh I've
got it but here's the problem is that
again Einstein says you can't solve a
problem at the same level of
consciousness that created the problem
every story begins with a dramatic
problem and what happens every writers
have this experience you get really
excited by your premise and you you
start writing it and you get halfway
through and then you get stuck and then
you're trying to make these characters
interesting but you feel like they're
just you know pieces on a chessboard
that you're trying to move around and
and and so it's important to understand
that story structure is not about
plotting story structure really is the
DNA of your protagonists transformation
and so what you really want to do is you
want to start to be curious about your
protagonists dilemma because when you
when you really understand the nature of
their struggle the nature of their
dilemma it is going it becomes the
source of your story and it starts to it
just starts to pay off in silver dollars
it starts to give you all sorts of ideas
images scenarios that are going to
become your plot okay but if you so so
here's the here's what I would suggest
if you want to come up with a great
outline the first thing we do in the 90
day novel in the 90 day screenplay is is
we spend one week imagining the world of
this story and doing absolutely no
outlining because what happens is I
would say our idea of our stories never
the whole story
if you start to outline your idea of
your story you're gonna get stuck you is
it's gonna become kind of a superficial
thing but if you allow yourself to lose
yourself in your characters relating to
other characters they're going to
surprise you they're gonna be alive and
they're gonna start to do things that
you might not have imagined had you
forced them into a prescribed outline
okay and so
that's the first step is imagine the
world of your story allow your
characters to be relating to each other
in ways without imposing any structure
any outline whatsoever now that you've
got all of this raw material and you
start to see how they're related I'll
give you an example you would never if
you're writing It's a Wonderful Life
what does he want he wants to leave
Bedford Falls in order to have a
wonderful life the midpoint of that is
where mr. Potter offers Jimmy Stewart a
job that would never if you're outlining
your story that has nothing to do with
what Jimmy Stewart wants okay
he's that's Jimmy mr. Potter's the the
devil okay's the enemy why would he ever
offer him a job that wouldn't make any
sense but if you're imagining the world
of the story and you come to the
midpoint structure question okay which
is how is your protagonist how does your
protagonist experience temptation it
might occur to you that the devil would
tempt him with a big job offer okay and
so that's where I feel like the way I
teach story structure is different then
I've been told it's different than
everybody and it's because there's no
plotting at all there's these structure
questions that are experiential
questions okay
so we're exploring it we're exploring
your the your protagonists experience at
key stages in the the journey okay I
hesitate to say the hero's journey
because then people get this fixed idea
oh you're teaching the hero's journey no
I'm actually not I'm teaching Motiti is
that story structure is an immutable
paradigm for a spiritual transformation
and that their key stages that one goes
through including the you know the
reluctance at the end of the first act
the the false hope which we just talked
about I'm talking about now the
mid-point temptation and then suffering
toward the end of the second act and
then finally surrender the end of the
the second act these are all experiences
reluctance false hope temptation
suffering surrender they have nothing to
do with plotting and we're not talking
about
reversal you know so as someone already
figuring out the ending in that in that
before their beginning us out line you
said think about it for a week or
whatever think about the the crux of the
story what is it really about are they
also figuring out the ending or is it
revealed sometimes after you do the
outline both it can get revealed after
you do the outline I don't like the word
figuring out because I don't think we
figure anything out but I have an
exercise that give my students - to
experience the ending and and and and
it's a two-part exercise I say imagine
your protagonist transformed at the end
of the story how is your protagonist
relating differently to other characters
at the end of the story how are they
related differently than they were at
the beginning and what do they
understand at the end of the story that
they didn't understand at the beginning
okay and so and then do that like every
day do that for like ten minutes every
day and and what you you start to plant
a flag for your protagonist at the end
of the story you start to experience
your protagonist at the end of the story
character suggests plot when you start
to experience your character relating
differently to these other characters
plot naturally emerges but you're not
figuring anything out if you try and
figure it out you're gonna get stuck and
then the second thing you want to do is
you want to imagine the if you want to
imagine the climax to your story
remember that we want our protagonist to
be active through the whole story you
want to have an active protagonist and
the challenge for writers is that we
tend to be sort of passive observers
we're always watching what's going on
and so when we sometimes put ourselves
into the protagonists situation
sometimes the protagonist can be the
least interesting character in the story
and so you want to find a way to make
them active the structured questions are
always going to make your protagonist
active at the climb actually want to
think about the difficult choice your
protagonist makes between what he or she
wants and what they need okay it's a
difficult choice so that's an action I'm
making a choice I'm thinking you're
pretending it has to make an act take an
action between what they want and what
they need so so
think in terms of like let's say I want
justice but I believe that when I get
revenge justice will be done
so what I want is is actually revenge
okay I want them to pay and what I need
is to have compassion okay so in other
words the end of the story the climax of
the story is we're gonna reframe our
relationship to the theme ie justice and
so I'm gonna put my protagonist in a
situation where he can have to make a
difficult choice between what he wants
revenge and what he needs is compassion
that's that
in other words if it's not a difficult
choice he would have made the choice in
act 1 but it's a it has to be difficult
and it doesn't have to be sometimes we
call it the battle scene the climax of
the story but it doesn't it doesn't have
to be an external battle it can be an
internal battle ok so so it doesn't have
to be it can be an internal battle that
gets dramatized like if you think about
Holly Hunter in broadcast news the
battle scene is her staring at a plane
ticket on a bench at the airport because
William Hurt says here's the ticket and
she what she wants is there to be is she
wants there to be integrity in broadcast
journalism but what she needs is to have
integrity
so when William Hurt crosses the line
and fakes a tear in this interview she's
furious and she wants him to take
responsibility for it so that she can go
after this exotic island for a week and
and and and and frolic with him but he's
not going to and and so she is forced to
make a difficult choice within herself
am I gonna get on the plane with William
Hurt or am I gonna get back in the cab
and and so that's that's the battle
scene but it's still active she makes
the choice of getting into the cab so
you want to find a way for your
protagonist to make a difficult choice
between what they want which there's
always outside of themselves ie William
Hurt and what they need which is
was within I'm going to do the right
thing
you